i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
welcome to the show i'm producer pat
ford filling in for david today as he is
traveling up in canada visiting our
neighbors to the north he has some
family members he's seeing up in
montreal so it's going to be me hosting
today as well as on monday and then we
actually have farron cousins who's going
to step in and guest host a couple of
shows for us next week we do have a
jam-packed show to get to today we're
going to be discussing everything from
the mar-a-lago raid to the new irs
agents to alex jones to marjory
taylor-greene but let's start things off
today by talking about how it's looking
even more unlikely that joe biden will
be running for a second term in 2024 now
even back when biden was campaigning in
2020 i thought that biden is just going
to be a one-term president if he wins
he's convinced himself that he is the
best shot at defeating donald trump and
getting our country back on a path to
normalcy so he'll win his one term he'll
accomplish whatever he can and then
he'll step aside and let someone else
take over and the real reason is his age
right biden would be 82 by the time that
he sworn in for a second term and 86 by
the time he'd leave office after eight
years i'm not trying to be ageist or
anything like that but there's just a
reality to the fact that the president
of the united states is the most
important job in the world you could
argue it's it's one of the most
stressful jobs out there and you're
always busy you have to make these
public appearances not everyone even
lives into their 80s let alone is
working into their 80s let alone has the
most important job arguably in the
entire world in their 80s so i don't
know if joe biden really wants to do
that and over the past couple of years
whenever a reporter has asked about
biden running again for a second term
the white house's position has always
been that biden intends to run but they
never make the full-on commitment
leaving them plenty of room to backtrack
if they decide that you know he's not
really going to be doing this the one
time that kamala harris overstepped and
said that he is going to be running her
office had to step back the statement
the next day uh well now we're hearing
from democratic representative carolyn
maloney who represents part of new york
city that off the record joe biden is
not running for president again bologna
was speaking to the new york times
editorial board and the exchange went
like this new york times's eleanor
randolph said quote should president
biden run again maloney said off the
record he's not running again new york
times is joyouti thoughtman definitely
mispronouncing that said not off the
record on the record maloney said on the
record no he should not run again so
there was a bit of confusion about this
on the record versus off the record
thing both the reporter and the
interviewee are supposed to confirm and
agree that something is off the record
before it's truly off the record which
you can see didn't happen here in this
exchange but her position sure sounded
like biden won't be running again for a
second term she also doesn't want him to
run again as to why maloney might not
want biden to run again that's probably
because of his sagging approval numbers
they haven't been doing all that well in
in recent months although it has ticked
up a little bit over the past couple of
weeks he's back to around 40 percent but
maybe maloney just sees biden as a
liability for the democrats and she
wants him to step aside and to get a new
face in there maloney later went on cnn
to apologize for the statement and to
say that biden's a great president and
she doesn't think that biden's going to
run again but she sure wants him to mr
president i apologize i want you to run
i happen to think you won't be running
but when you run or if you run i will be
there 100
you have deserved it you are a great
president and
thank you for everything you've done for
my state and all the states and all the
cities in america thank you mr president
okay so a little awkward there and it's
a little bit unbelievable too because
while she is holding firm that she
doesn't believe biden will be running
again she also doesn't sound that
sincere that she wants biden to run
again i happen to believe her earlier
comments about it are true rather than
this apology and correction and the real
question in this conversation is do
democrats have a better chance at
holding the white house if it's joe
biden at the top of the ticket in 2024
versus if it's someone else fill in the
blank you know it could be kamala harris
gavin newsom elizabeth warren pete
buddha judge whoever i could be swayed
either way on this because helping biden
of course is the power of incumbency
presidents do tend to win re-election
more often than not but then there's
also these liabilities right like
there's biden's advanced age
that'll be even more of a liability the
next time around because he'll be four
years older there's also his approval
ratings which at least now aren't so
good maybe they'll improve between now
and the next election there's also the
question of if republicans are able to
take back the house and or senate will
biden be able to get all that much
accomplished probably not so then that's
hard to make the case to the voters that
you should re-elect him so to me it
seems a little bit too early to tell
what's going to happen for sure but i'm
sticking with my position that i don't
think that joe biden is going to be
running for president again in 2024 and
you better believe that that will set us
up for an interesting election cycle if
he chooses not to run again because then
both the democrats and the republicans
will have to be having these contested
primaries to see who their respective
nominees will be and that will
definitely be entertaining and juicy to
cover conspiracy theorists and infowars
host alex jones has made it clear that
he is done with donald trump and he is
indeed going to be backing ron desantis
if the florida governor decides to run
for president in 2024 now as much as i'd
like to say who cares what alex jones
says who cares what he thinks the guy's
a nut case after all we can dismiss him
this actually is pretty significant
because if he's able to turn his loyal
viewers and listeners from being trump
supporters and make them run to santa's
voters well that could make the
difference in a potential contested
primary between the two candidates let's
take a look at what jones had to say on
his infowars program earlier this week
pigheadedly support him
a few years ago even though i disagree
with his warp speed
because i
thought that we had to keep him in
office because of the nightmare scenario
if hillary or biden got in
back before they were officially running
but that said i am supporting desantis
the santas is just gone from being
awesome to being
unbelievably good
and i don't just watch a man's actions
as christ said judge a tree by his
fruits
i can also look in his eyes on hd video
and i see the real sincerity this is
what trump should be like and i've been
hammering this point
and he's doing it now
and
we have someone that is better than
trump
way better than trump now at least in
this clip alex jones didn't articulate
why exactly he likes ron desantis more
than donald trump i'd imagine it has
somewhat to do with the right-wing
culture war issues that desantis has
been championing over the past couple of
years everything from making these
decrees against socialism to passing his
don't say gay bill to the anti-trans
rhetoric to saying that oh well the left
supposedly wants to defund the police
but here in florida we're funding the
police but the real sticking point for
jones seems to be the vaccine issue the
fact that donald trump is not an
outright anti-vaxxer at least as it
pertains to the coveted vaccine and
that's really just because he wants to
take credit for it credit for operation
warp speed and jones predicted of course
that the vaccine would do all these
terrible things but then you look back
and after billions of doses have been
administered everyone's doing just fine
so maybe he's moved the goal posts on
that just as a reminder here's a clip
from back in december when alex jones
did a special emergency christmas day
edition of his show to declare that
trump is ignorant or evil because of his
stance on the coveted vaccines this is
an emergency christmas day warning to
president trump you were either
completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped ram through with
operation warp speed
or you're one of the most evil men who
has ever lived
to push
this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and
the lives of others we're about to lay
out the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told candace owens just a
few days ago is nothing but a raft of
dirty lies now maybe it's illogical for
me to try to get inside the head of alex
jones and understand why exactly he's
making this pivot and who knows if jones
even believes half the things that he
says right so maybe he doesn't even care
one way or another between trump or
desantis but it is a little bit strange
right because when jones decided to hit
his wagon to trump back in 2016 it at
least made a little bit of sense because
trump at the time was painting himself
as an anti-establishment figure he was
going to be an outsider who would shake
things up in washington and drain the
swamp as he liked to say ron desantis
though on the other hand he's pretty
much just a standard republican like he
he knows how to play the culture war
games better than the average republican
politician and he's clearly learned a
thing or two from trump about how to
deal with the media and how to present
himself but at the end of the day he's a
pretty establishment guy which jones has
really never been into so it's all very
weird and i do think it actually could
be relevant to a potential matchup
between the two figures so we'll have to
see if maybe ron desantis ever decides
to appear on alex jones show like donald
trump did back in 2016. maybe he won't
because desantis may realize that jones
is a little bit too toxic right now to
associate with but that's the latest
alex jones done with donald trump and
moving over to ron desantis marjorie
taylor greene is a full-throated
supporter of donald trump's big lie and
unlike most republican politicians who
simply pay lip service to the idea that
trump was robbed and biden committed
voter fraud along with the democrats i
actually do believe that green believes
this conspiracy theory because she's
never met a conspiracy theory that she
didn't like and she loves donald trump
so much you match those things together
and poof you have someone who is going
to fall for the big lie well the georgia
congresswoman is now making the case
that this midterm season in order to
fight the massive amounts of voter fraud
that's supposedly being committed by the
left republican voters have to go out
and vote not just once but maybe two or
three times now she could have been
making a joke here but even if so she
probably shouldn't be saying it and
we'll get to why exactly in a little bit
but first here's the clip of her saying
it have hope
fight support people like representative
greene get out and vote with you and
your 20 closest friends and neighbors in
november
and 40 vote
thank you so much for being here for the
hope for your fight and for
communicating with us absolutely
appreciate you always welcome
thank you thank you so much well good
for mallory staples at least for jumping
in there and saying hold on we don't
encourage any law breaking do whatever
the law will allow you to do but then
again the two are making it sound like
the law will allow you to do anything in
georgia you can vote multiple times and
all these different things like it's one
big joke right that's not good for trust
in our democratic process now this
reminds me of the 2020 election during
the presidential campaign when donald
trump went to north carolina and he told
people to submit an absentee ballot and
then also to go to the polls in person
and try to vote that way which yes is
very much a crime that would be voting
twice that's actual voter fraud which
you can't get away with it was arguably
a crime for donald trump to encourage
this as well but surprise surprise he
didn't face any consequences for it six
hundred thousand people could vote by
absentee in this state i don't know are
you confident in that system well
they'll go out and they'll vote and
they're gonna have to go and check their
vote by going to the poll and voting
that way because uh if it tabulates then
they won't be able to do that so
let them send it in and let them go vote
and if their system's as good as they
say it is then obviously they won't be
able to vote if it isn't tabulated
they'll be able to vote so that's the
way it is and that's what they should do
now the problem when people like
marjorie taylor green and donald trump
go out and make statements like this is
that people actually take their word for
it and act upon it we've seen a number
of examples from the 2020 election of
people doing this here's just a few
residents of trump-loving retirement
community arrested for allegedly voting
twice in 2020 election this took place
at the villages in florida and then we
have republican official in ohio facing
charges for voting twice in the november
election there's plenty more examples
we've covered them on the show over the
past couple of years and it makes sense
right because these republican voters
want to take action in their own hands
they think that democrats are doing this
left and right so they might as well
fight fire with fire and vote two or
three times themselves even though
there's no basis for the claims that
donald trump and his supporters have
been making about the voter fraud issue
and i wouldn't be surprised if in the
2022 midterms we see even more examples
right because they've really ramped up
the rhetoric about supposed voter fraud
over the last couple of years and so i'm
sure we'll have dozens to talk about for
you after the midterms are over with and
when confronted with how people are
doing this on republicans behalf i'm
sure marjorie taylor green will just
laugh it off or claim that it's not
happening or she'll just ignore it all
together but it's incredibly
irresponsible for marjorie taylor greene
to do this and i'm sure she doesn't care
at all all right we're going to throw to
a break we'll be back with much more of
the david pakman show after this
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com
pacman you will get aura free for 14
days which you can use to do things like
see if your passwords have been leaked
the link is down below
with young and deeply unqualified
congressman madison cawthorne losing his
primary challenge in north carolina
there was apparently an opening in the
tar heel state for another 20-something
year old republican to enter congress
and be in completely over their head
insert bow hinds 26 years old who is
running for congress on the republican
ticket to represent the 13th district of
north carolina he made headlines this
week for
not knowing the definition of a banana
republic and confusing it with the
retail clothing store he did this while
trying to make the point by the way that
it is joe biden who is the one who is
incompetent and incoherent heinz was on
the john fredericks radio show and the
two were talking about the fbi raid on
donald trump and the biden
administration's plan to hire more irs
agents republicans lately have loved to
lump these two issues together as if
they have anything to do with one
another they don't more on that on the
show later
and then beau made the case that even
though there's all these corrupt people
in the highest ranks of our government
it's not fair to call the united states
a banana republic because that's an
insult to banana republic stores all
across the country let's take a look at
the clip you get the congress
is it going to be real are we actually
going to be willing to defund irs fbi
and things of that nature well i mean we
have to i mean we're at a point in our
country now where we have a unregulated
fourth branch of government that's
targeting middle class americans on a
daily basis i mean it's unbelievable
what we're saying you know a lot of
people liking the situation that's going
on right now is you know they say we're
in a banana republic i think that's an
insult to banana republics across the
country i mean at least the manager of
banana republic unlike our president
knows where he is and why he's there and
what he's doing i mean we have a
president right now that doesn't know
where he is doesn't know who he is or
what time it is and he's attempting to
run our country at the same time this
fourth unregulated branch of government
which is the fbi the doj targeting
americans every single day i mean it's
unbelievable my absolute favorite part
of that clip is the radio host's
reaction to it all he has this look of
oh crap this guy doesn't know what a
banana republic is should i correct him
should i just let it slide what exactly
do i do how do i run cover for what's
going on here now the campaign is in
damage control mode they're trying to
say that this was all just a joke even
though there was no laugh or smile or
indication at all that what he was
saying was in jest rob burgess his
senior advisor said in response it's
clear now that the american people can
add understand a joke to the
ever-growing list of things democrats
simply can't comprehend alongside the
economy public safety education and
foreign policy just to name a few so
he's trying to brush it off as just a
joke before quickly transitioning to
these other topics which i actually have
to give burgess credit for because these
are actual issues facing the country
it's not just the typical culture war
nonsense that the right loves to talk
about these days so definitely this is a
funny story but it actually serves as a
reminder to
maybe retire the term banana republic
because it is often used as a pejorative
against latin american countries it
describes a small country that's
politically and economically unstable
and relies too much on exporting natural
resources the term was actually coined
to describe countries that were being
exploited by american companies like the
united fruit company which is now
chiquita brands which was a state
favored monopoly that exploited latin
american workers for profit for many
years maybe once we retire the term only
the retail store will be left with the
name banana republic and then beau hines
will be vindicated he'll be correct if
he ever tries to make this a statement
again we'll follow up on this race
because heinz is up against democrat
wiley nickel and the contest is seen as
a toss-up maybe a slight edge to heinz
but it's definitely winnable so we'll
have to see if we'll be able to win this
race the pennsylvania senate race is one
of the most interesting elections this
mid-term cycle as it presents democrats
with an opportunity to pick up a seat in
the upper chamber and add to their
majority democratic nominee john
fetterman is up against republican
member oz and this race was considered a
toss-up just a couple of months ago but
it's now looking like fetterman really
is pulling away the 538 average of
polling has fettermen up by 11 points 49
to 38
and part of this can be expected because
pennsylvania still after all is a blue
state yes they did vote for trump in
2016. they've put people in power like
rick santorum
and pat toomey but this is still blue
territory we can say but another part of
the reason is that mehmet oz dr oz he
really just seems to be a lot weaker of
a candidate than many of us even
expected he's been painted successfully
as a carpetbagger because he's from new
jersey he's been painted as an elitist
which is also true because he has a net
worth of about a hundred million dollars
with ten houses more on that later on
today's bonus show uh we actually talked
earlier in the week on the bonus show
about his crudite video which was filmed
back in april but it's going viral now
and john fetterman was mocking him for
it because he didn't know the name of
the grocery store that he was in he
didn't know how buying vegetables works
and oftentimes the price that's listed
is the price per pound versus the price
per vegetable uh so the fetterman
campaign was having a field day trolling
him for that well the oz team is
realizing that they have to make up some
ground and they've decided to go on the
offense they did so by releasing an
attack ad on john fetterman and i don't
think it's going to work out too well
for them let's take a look at the ad
now that john fetterman claims to be
recovering let's pull back his hoodie
and examine what's in his head
looks like he has some screws loose
what's this
fetterman wants to release one third of
all prisoners that's crazy
spend more tax dollars everything will
cost more that's nuts
slow energy production
gas prices will skyrocket
that's ridiculous
socialized medicine
you get these crazy ideas
john fetterman is crazier than you think
all right so in the ad they attacked
john fetterman for wearing a hoodie
which actually can be argued as an asset
for him the fact that he just dresses
like the average pennsylvania dude he's
not trying to be anything that he's not
he's not wearing a suit and tie just for
the show he likes wearing his basketball
shorts and his sweatshirts so i don't
know if that's going to be all that
effective for the oz campaign
then there's this bong that pops out of
fetterman's head and i couldn't find out
whether fetterman himself uses cannabis
but he is one of the most pro-weed
politicians in america he supported it
long before it was politically popular
to do so and the latest poll that i
could find was that 58 of pennsylvanians
support legalizing marijuana so i don't
see how that is much of an attack either
then there's this bit about releasing a
third of prisoners well we do have the
world's highest prison population and if
you're talking about releasing people
who are non-violent people who are maybe
drug offenders that sort of thing yeah
they should be led out of prison that's
totally cool uh by the way i thought
republicans were all of a sudden more
amenable to this idea of prison and
criminal justice reform because they
think that the january 6th rioters are
spending too much time behind bars maybe
they forgot about that over at the oz
campaign then there's the thing about
slowing energy production clearly that's
over the course of many years and
decades though to move in the direction
of renewable power that will ultimately
save people money by the way and save
the planet in the long term and then
they put up the phrase free health care
being held up on a sign by aoc which
they should have known that they they
shouldn't have used the term free health
care or universal health care it would
have been much better if they used the
term government takeover of health care
they said in the ad socialized medicine
but they should have put that on the
sign as well because that's the type of
phrase that pulls a lot better for
republicans and then out pops bernie
sanders who is apparently the one who's
really controlling jon fetterman if you
vote for john fetterman you're actually
getting bernie sanders i think this is
another blunder too because yeah bernie
wasn't popular enough to win the
democratic primary for example either in
2016 or 2020 but he is quite popular as
a politician people think that he's
principled and he's especially popular
in the northeast in states like vermont
where he represents and you know
pennsylvania's pretty close by too so
i'd imagine he's pretty popular there so
even though i'm no republican i think
that i could have done a much better job
at making this attack ad on john
fetterman because this just looks
absolutely cartoonish it's a terrible
presentation very over the top and i
think the odds team could have done a
lot better let's hope that fetterman is
able to grow or at least maintain his
lead will be able to land donald trump
another loss if peterman picks up the
victory here but you know what trump
will do if memonized ends up losing
he'll just distance himself from oz and
say well oz didn't really run all that
close to me and that's why he lost but
nonetheless it will be a glorious
victory if we're able to pick up this
seat in pennsylvania
did donald trump as president have the
right to unilaterally declassify
documents just based on his say-so
that's one of the conversations we've
been having ever since the fbi raid on
donald trump's home in florida last week
took place and we know that the american
right wing they've been throwing
everything at the wall to see what
sticks as it pertains to the fbi raid in
mar-a-lago saying everything from this
is a witch hunt to the fbi planted
documents on donald trump but one of the
more pernicious claims made in
right-wing media circles lately has been
that even if donald trump did have
classified documents in his possession
in his basement in mar-a-lago that's
a-okay because presidents at the end of
the day are the ultimate authority as to
what is classified information and what
gets declassified so it doesn't matter
it's kind of a get out of jail free card
if the president does it it's not
illegal as richard nixon once said
here's one such example of this claim
being made by cash patel who is a former
trump administration official who now
works over at truth social also known as
troth central uh he made the claim to
fox news's maria bartoromo over the
weekend on her sunday show let's take a
look at that in october of 2020 he
issued a sweeping declassification order
for every russia gate document in every
single hillary clinton document then on
the way out of the white house he issued
further declassification orders
declassifying whole sets of documents
and this is a key fact that most
americans are missing president trump as
the sitting president is a unilateral
authority for declassification he can
literally stand over a set of documents
and say these are now declassified and
that is done with definitive action
immediately so cash patel here in this
video makes it sound like there's almost
a magic spell involved like donald trump
can just wave his hand over the
documents in question and then poof they
are no longer classified information so
nothing to be seen here nothing to be
investigated well you may be shocked to
learn that this is not actually how the
process works presidents do have the
ability to declassify certain types of
information but there's a procedure
attached to it certain executive branch
officials have the authority to deem
information as confidential secret or
top secret and if it's ultra top secret
then the the document will get the sci
designation some of the documents in
donald trump's possession had this very
distinction there are also rules
limiting how the documents can be stored
physically transported or electronically
transmitted when someone with the proper
authority moves to declassify the
documents the executive branch has a
process to involve the other agencies
that might be affected and certainly the
president is one of the people who can
move to make something declassified it's
rarely done but it can happen however
they need to undergo this very same
process and it's not as easy as major
waving a magic wand as cash patel would
have you believe here's former cia
director and former defense secretary
leon panetta who would know a thing or
two about this very topic being even
more frank than i have been about the
process for how to declassify documents
so you're obviously very well versed in
dealing with classified material former
trump aides are now trying to claim that
there was a standing order by the
president donald trump to declassify any
document that left the west wing for
trump's resident is that how
declassification works even with some of
the nation's most guarded secrets
uh you know that's nonsense and uh and
he knows it
uh the reality is that there is a
process
for declassifying information
uh and if presidents want to declassify
they have to follow that process which
basically requires that it be referred
to the agencies that are responsible for
classifying that material
they have something to say as to whether
or not that material should be
declassified so
there is
nothing
that i'm aware of
that indicates that a formal step was
taken by this president to in fact
declassify anything right now this is
pretty much bs it's all a bunch of bs
says leon panetta and then there's an
added layer of security when you're
talking about nuclear documents which
donald trump is accused of having in his
possession as documents about nuclear
material are subject to the atomic
energy act which the president does not
have unilateral authority over now
secondary to this entire discussion is
that even if the documents weren't
classified or even if they were deemed
declassified by donald trump right
before he left office with his magic
wand it wouldn't serve to get the former
president out of hot water because none
of the things that donald trump is being
investigated for require the documents
be
classified the espionage act violations
concealing documents and obstruction of
justice are the three things that the
fbi is looking into as it pertains to
donald trump those are not dependent on
whether the information that trump had
in his possession were classified he's
not supposed to be taking hiding or
destroying any of the presidential
records regardless of their
classification status and the government
asked him to return the items he didn't
willingly hand them over he didn't give
back all of the documents anyway and so
it doesn't matter whether or not they
were classified final point on this
because the wright has been talking
non-stop about hillary clinton and her
emails over the past couple of weeks
they used to say that hillary clinton
she could not be trusted to handle
secret information therefore she could
not be president because when she was
secretary of state she had uh secret
documents in her gmail account that was
being operated through a private server
and it was grossly negligent we just
can't trust her with these top secret
documents well if that was ever your
concern
but you also now have this position that
the president can just declassify
whatever they want on a whim doesn't
this render the point that they were
making about hillary in 2016 completely
moot like why would it matter that
hillary clinton supposedly uh wasn't
able to be trusted with classified
information if she would have the power
as president to just declassify whatever
she wants anyway but the contradictions
we know when it comes to the right wing
they don't matter it's all about
twisting and turning yourself anything
that you can do to defend donald trump
no matter how ridiculous it makes you
look fox news host tucker carlson was
off last week i'm sure many of you were
absolutely devastated by this there was
even a conspiracy theory floating around
that the fbi waited to raid donald
trump's home in florida until tucker
carlson was off the airwaves so that he
wouldn't be in studio to give a fiery
response to it all well one of the guest
hosts last week for tucker was brian
kilmeade who oops aired a doctored photo
of the judge who signed off on the
search warrant of donald trump depicting
him hanging out with elaine maxwell but
the host on last friday's show is the
one i want to talk about here today and
that was none other than tulsi gabbard
which may come as a shock to you all
right because tulsi gabbard i thought
she was a liberal she ran for president
in 2020 on the democratic side she was
called even more progressive and more
principled than bernie sanders of all
people well it's not clear that she ever
was those things or ever held strong
ideological beliefs at all or if she was
always grifting or as some alleged that
she's working for a foreign country
that's what hillary clinton said
she's been inching tulsi that is more
and more to the right over time going on
fox news voting present on donald
trump's impeachment vote to heal the
country and she also spoke at cpac last
year and now the grift is complete
because she has filled in for tucker
carlson on his show tucker carlson
tonight and what did she do during the
show did she talk about universal health
care or did she talk about criminal
justice reform or any of these other
issues that a true progressive would
want to share with the fox news audience
no she instead decided to run
interference for donald trump let's
watch some of tulsi's monologue and pick
it apart and see if there's anything
progressive here at all in this
commentary or if it's like anything else
that you could find from a fox news
personality now whatever your views are
on donald trump there's no denying that
the unprecedented raid on his palm beach
home earlier this week has set our
country on a dangerous new course and
there's no turning back the fbi's radon
mar-a-lago
changed the country that we grew up and
we grew up believing that hey our
government will apply the law equally to
all americans whether you're a
republican or a democrat we're seeing
more and more that that country no
longer exists okay so we're only 26
seconds into the monologue and i already
have to cut it short and step in here
because there's already a lot to break
down so tulsi says that the raid in
mar-a-lago was unprecedented which yes
it was but also what donald trump did as
president and what he's accused of doing
in a criminal context that's also
unprecedented so as david likes to say
when you have unique inputs you're going
to have unique outputs just by saying
that what the fbi and the doj did was
unprecedented that doesn't mean that it
was necessarily wrong or unjustified
tulsi then talks about how the fbi raid
has set us on a dangerous course from
which we cannot turn back again it was
donald trump who set us on this course
the fbi was merely responding to the
actions that the former president
allegedly did as is their job as a law
enforcement agency that is after all
what they do and then tulsi appeals to
the elderly fox news demographic by
giving this rainbows and rose petals and
gumdrop depiction of the america we once
knew the america that we knew growing up
saying that that america is long gone
because now the law is no longer being
applied equally and this is dumb for a
couple of reasons like for one it never
really was this way we never really had
this glossy depiction of america and
having a perfect criminal justice system
we've always had a two-tiered justice
system especially as it breaks down on
racial and class lines but then also
what the fbi and the doj are doing
investigating donald trump because they
believe he committed crimes that is
applying the law equally applying the
law unequally would be saying like okay
well we think he's guilty we think that
he did illegal stuff here but he's a
former president after all he's a
billionaire he's a powerful person so
we're going to let him get away with it
we're just going to look the other way
so that would be unjustified that would
be a backwards depiction of the country
so it's taken me what two minutes here
to break down the nonsense that tulsi
was able to spew in 26 seconds let's
keep playing the clip and see if it gets
any better at all
law enforcement at the highest levels of
government whether it's the doj the
department of homeland security the fbi
and now even the irs have been
weaponized to target the political
opponents of the uniparty the permanent
washington and the biden regime
attorney general merrick garland has
already issued a stark warning to anyone
who dares to disagree with these tactics
that are all hallmarks of a dictatorship
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi
and justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
so you are not allowed to disagree with
the fbi that is the new message all
right so we again have to stop it here
and jump in so telsey first brings up
the story about biden hiring a bunch of
new irs agents by way of the inflation
reduction act as a way to raise funds
for government programs and to make sure
that people making over four hundred
thousand dollars a year aren't cheating
too much on their taxes she tries to tie
that in with the fbi's investigation of
donald trump
objection relevance how are these two
things related in the slightest they're
they're not uh and then tulsi plays a
clip of merrick garland refuting the
idea that the doj isn't just following
the law and that there's some political
motivations behind what they're doing
and tulsi twists that into saying you're
not allowed to disagree with the fbi as
if your free speech rights are being
curtailed that's even what they had as
the lower third graphic
you're not allowed to disagree with the
fbi completely absurd and definitely a
manipulation of the video that she
played so there's tulsi gabbard for you
filling in for tucker carlson definitely
taking a page or two out of his
propaganda playbook it's long been
speculated that tulsi is vying for a job
at fox news and after seeing that what
was clearly an audition it does feel
like that's the career path that her
career is heading in uh when she left
congress at the beginning of last year
there was speculation as to what was
next for tulsi i always thought it was a
fox news gig and i'm surprised it hasn't
happened yet maybe they just want to
have her train a little bit more with
these guest appearances maybe they're
trying to find the right dollar amount
for her salary
maybe they're trying to figure out what
the best time slot is for her but i
wouldn't be surprised at all if in the
next six months tulsi has her own show
on fox news we're gonna go to a break
we'll be back with more of the david
pakman show right after this
the american right wing has a number of
boogeymen but one that has withstood the
test of time is the irs which is why
many on the right right now are going
apoplectic over the bind
administration's plan to hire 87 000 new
irs agents with the 80 billion dollars
that they're getting from the inflation
reduction act as a way to beef up tax
enforcement and ultimately increase
revenue for the federal government so
the right they're trying to tie in the
fbi raid of donald trump's home
with the hiring of these irs agents as
if the two things have anything to do
with one another i already showed you a
clip of tulsi gabbard trying to connect
these dots earlier in the program but
she's not the only one we also have
florida senator marco rubio who asked
after today's raid on mar-a-lago what do
you think the left plans to use those 87
000 new agents for
rick grinnell a former trump
administration official tweeted quote
the fbi raids trump's house and the
democrats vote to add 87 000 new irs
agents to go after americans wake up
america and then we have indiana
congressman jim banks who said if the
fbi can raid the home of a former
president imagine what 87 000 more irs
agents will do to you
well the only connection that i can see
between these two things is that they
involve agencies at the federal
government under the executive branch
but aside from that it seems pretty
weird to lump these two things together
unless you want to fearmonger and not
care about the facts
but then the rhetoric starts to get
dangerous because when you hear from
some of these right-wing personalities
they're trying to talk about how the
bind administration wants to not only
add to the irs force they also want to
give them new weapons brian kilmeade for
example suggested on fox news last week
that these new irs agents are ready to
hunt down and kill middle class
taxpayers with the weapons that they
have let's take a look at the video the
so-called inflation reduction act also
says the 80 billion dollar budget is for
quote increased enforcement operational
improvements and customer service what
kind of customer service we don't have
to wonder before the irs took it down
yesterday there was a posting watch this
on their website they listed the job
requirements for a special agent's
position the major duties require agents
to quote carry a firearm and be willing
to use deadly force if necessary
a little like james bond but instead of
hunting down evil maniacs these agents
hunt down and kill middle class
taxpayers that don't pay enough it's joe
biden's new army americans are
rightfully concerned about this got a
new poll i'll share with you shows 45 of
the country fears the irs will increase
the number of audits according to the
cnbc which is another business network
the second best financial experts are
predicting the bill will spark more
audits for small business owners so what
brian kilmeade was referring to in this
clip is the irs's criminal investigation
division which is nothing new it's been
around for over a hundred years they've
always had firearms training and it's
because they go after things like money
laundering schemes and cyber crime in
situations that could get violent or
deadly and so it makes sense for those
agents to be armed but the average irs
auditor when undergoing a routine audit
of someone is unarmed no surprise there
we also had iowa senator chuck grassley
making this very same point that
killmead made he went on fox and friends
and said quote are they going to have a
strike force that goes in with ak-15s
already loaded ready to shoot some small
business person in iowa so first of all
he said ak-15 which i thought wasn't a
gun i thought he was mixing up ar-15s
and ak-47s he may have mixed them up but
luckily he gets a pass because it is a
gun that exists although it's quite rare
but if he was a democrat and the gun
didn't exist you better believe he would
be raked over the coals for making a
statement like that and not having an
understanding of firearms but he just
barely passed the test there but the
broader point to his question is that no
he's just trying to feed into a
conspiracy theory as to what the bind
administration wants to accomplish by
hiring all these agents and acting like
it's something nefarious or out of the
ordinary but also the very idea that
these agents are going to go after
people who make fifty thousand dollars a
year sixty seventy thousand dollars a
year it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense because first of all they've
already said and it's out been outlined
in the text you can look at it they're
only going to look after uh look for
trying to recover money from people who
make four hundred thousand dollars a
year or more but if you don't take them
at their word just think about it
logically just look at the math of the
situation so does it make sense as an
agency when you have limited time money
resources to go after joe schmoe who
makes 50k a year with the hopes of maybe
recovering an extra couple hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars or does it
make sense to put that time and energy
into scrutinizing someone who makes 10
million dollars a year or more with the
idea that maybe you can recover another
million dollars couple of million
dollars obviously it makes sense to
investigate the wealthy and also more
revenue for the government means that
we're going to be able to lower our debt
and deficit all else being equal i
thought that the right wing was in
support of that but of course we know
that debt and deficit they're a
political football which at this point
it's just not all that convenient for
republicans to play with so they'll put
that issue aside for now
so on multiple fronts the right-wing
fear-mongering about these new irs
agents doesn't make a whole lot of sense
but it's the perfect opportunity for
millionaires and billionaires the people
who
are in charge over at fox news to
convince middle-class earners that the
irs is going to come after them so that
they're opposed to the inflation
reduction act they're opposed to move
like this even though it's really not
going to affect them at all it's going
to impact the big money earners and
that's exactly what fox news and the
right wing media sphere does best a 16
year old pregnant girl in florida will
not be able to get an abortion because a
court has decided that she is not
sufficiently mature enough to decide for
herself whether it's the right decision
to carry the fetus to term or to get an
abortion this is absolute madness the
girl's name is not being provided as she
is under 18 and they want to protect her
identity but florida has a new 15-week
abortion ban the constitutionality of
which is being questioned but it's
staying in place for now at least the
state brought that threshold down from
the 24 weeks back a couple months ago
and there is a state law in florida that
requires minors to get parental consent
for an abortion which i would argue
should not be necessary because
even though you're a minor it's still
your body after all it's still going to
be a decision that involves you for the
next 18 years plus so it seems like they
only had this rule in place as a way to
embarrass the girl who becomes pregnant
to have to have her go to her parents
and explain the situation that she's in
and try to get their approval but as it
pertains to this story the girl in
question could not get her parental
consent because she is parentless and
she lives with a relative and has an
appointed guardian but that wasn't good
enough for a circuit court judge who
denied the parental consent waiver and a
three-judge panel upheld the decision a
statement from the appeals court said
the appellant had not established by
clear and convincing evidence that she
was sufficiently mature to decide
whether to terminate her pregnancy so
per the state of florida the girl is not
mature enough to decide whether an
abortion makes sense for her yet she is
somehow mature enough to carry a baby to
term give birth and raise it to
adulthood how does that make any sense
at all
something tells me that being a parent
requires a lot more maturity than
deciding whether a medical procedure for
someone in your position makes sense for
you so this is just the latest example
of republican barbarity on the topic
like in the lead up to roe vs wade
getting overturned when we could kind of
see the writing on the wall because of
trump's supreme court justices and then
when the draft opinion was leaked and
then when it was made official back in
june all along the right wing assured
the rest of the country that they were
going to be responsible on this abortion
issue if roe got overturned that they
would not be completely draconian and
how they addressed the matter
and they would say things like oh well
we'll have exceptions for rape well now
that's being put into question because
they realized how logistically
challenging that would be because it
could easily lead to an increase in
false rape accusations then they'd say
things like oh well there'll be
exceptions for life of the mother when
the life the mother is put at risk
you'll be able to get an abortion in
that instance but now they're realizing
that you can't always assess risk levels
in this way where it's like a hundred
percent that the mother's going to
survive if she has the child or 100
chance that she's going to die if she
has a child like usually it's in this
gray area where you don't know with any
certainty what's going to happen so
who's going to decide whether or not you
fit under that exception for life of the
mother and they also used to say oh well
if roe versus wade gets overturned then
you're going to be able to travel to a
different state to get an abortion if
it's illegal in your state now we're
starting to see states try to
criminalize that very practice as well
so the reality has been a lot more
draconian than many of us could have
even imagined and if there's any silver
lining at all in the horrors that these
countless women have had to deal with
across the country including in this
story
it's that maybe it will incentivize
people to go out and vote in the fall
maybe democrats will be able to
ultimately hold on to the house of
representatives maybe they'll be able to
pick up a couple of seats in the senate
so that we can move to eliminate the
filibuster and work to codify roe versus
wade into law that has to be the path
forward because we absolutely cannot
trust republicans with control over this
abortion issue and sadly we're probably
going to see plenty more cases like this
one out of florida it's absolutely
sickening if you've been watching the
show for a while or if you're just aware
of the american system of government
more generally then you'll know what
gerrymandering is very simply it's when
state legislatures drop district maps in
a way that will benefit them the party
that's already in control gets to do
this so it's effectively a way for
politicians to choose their voters
rather than voters choosing their
politicians so for example if you're a
republican state but you have a big
democratic city in the state and let's
say you're awarded five districts from
the census that gets done every ten
years you may decide to make the city
one district with the more rural areas
four separate districts so then you'll
have a four to one advantage or if you
can get away with it maybe you'll break
up that city into five pieces combining
those pieces with the more rural areas
that may outweigh the parts of the city
in population so then you can get a five
to zero advantage that's kind of how it
works it's a practice that really has to
be done away with and there are laws
against going too far with it like by
breaking up districts by ethnic
neighborhoods
you can't you can't do too much with
that these districts have to be
contiguous but the states over the years
have been able to get away with quite a
lot as it pertains to redistricting like
for example let's take a look at this
map
here is a picture of dan crenshaw's
oddly shaped district in the houston
area it looks like maybe a salamander if
you can say that it resembles anything
at all so this is some pretty extreme
gerrymandering here well every now and
then the courts will step in and strike
down one of these egregiously
gerrymandered maps which is good to see
because that means that there's some
accountability at least but the problem
is that it's often too little too late
and we may go through an election cycle
or two or three or four before these
illegally drawn districts can be
corrected and that's exactly the
situation that we're finding ourselves
in now going into the 2022 midterms
since january district maps in the
republican-controlled states of alabama
georgia louisiana and ohio have been
deemed unlawful but rather than putting
an immediate stop to it they've been
allowed to go forward for this election
cycle the states are challenging their
respective judges rulings and the plan
is to just figure it all out later and
it's not an insignificant number of
seats too it's about 10 percent of seats
in the house of representatives that are
affected by this ruling and it's going
to end up awarding republicans about
five to seven seats that they otherwise
wouldn't be able to win they're just
going to be essentially entitled to
these seats keep in mind republicans
only need to pick up about 10 seats or
even fewer potentially to win back the
house in 2022 so this is definitely the
type of thing that we need emergency
relief on right we need the supreme
court to step in and say no you can't
use these maps they've been determined
to be illegal and you can't use it for
the midterms but predictably they're
quite laxed on this issue the supreme
court is very conservative right now six
to three conservative and this is the
type of ruling that's going to benefit
them and their political side in the
meantime so they're happy to see it be
allowed to be used because they know
that it's going to increase their power
so they're totally fine with it they're
not going to step in
and it's yet another example of the 2016
election
rearing its ugly head and uh how donald
trump being able to appoint those three
supreme court justices has put us in a
terrible position as a country and it's
also part of the reason why 538 right
now expects that republicans have about
a 79 80 chance of winning back the lower
chamber in 2022 sure it's not just this
issue it's other things too like we
probably should have picked up more
seats in the house in 2020 there's also
the historical trend of how the party in
charge that has the white house tends to
have a bad first midterm so there's
other things working against us sure but
also gerrymandering plays a significant
role and it's really something that we
cannot have in a functioning democracy
something that we have to work on and we
have to fix this process or at least
have a way to undo these maps
immediately when they're determined to
be illegal all right that's going to do
it for today's episode of the david
pakman show my thank you to david for
allowing me to fill in today as he is up
in canada at the moment have a great
weekend everybody and i'm going to be
back on monday posting once again see
you then
i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below